i don't like how i i
material things are truly not important
to your quality of life
i agree i i really think i i want to
hammer that home before i say this yes
but at the same
time driven a singer there there is
there is
something weird happening now where
you're supposed to be
ashamed of success yes in a way that i
don't like
um and i and i really like what i really
love is
um my armenian friends because they
don't
my grandpa move away from armenia come
here turks kill his family
i drive mercedes [ __ ] you [ __ ] you gold
chains
[ __ ] you i love that because it's like
no you're right yeah you know what you
[ __ ] your family work for your ass
off to develop
wealth be proud of it they're
entrepreneurial they're yeah they're
celebrating and i subscribe to that
because
you know when i post my cars or the bike
or something like that
the older heads you wrote you got your
dalia
a little bit with me but my my peers my
the older guys who are my best friends
rogan would say never post your car
never ever post any of that don't let
people know
how well you're doing but i subscribed
to a different
younger generation where they came
they're seeing it they came with me on
the journey where
i was this fighter where i can afford
anything and but i started a podcast
and they came with me on the right so
when i post stuff
of that they go oh [ __ ] yeah dude
because they know what went in the game
right no absolutely
absolutely and it's almost like hey
check it out we did it i agree with both
schools too right where i think i get
both sides i don't i
agree in a country where there's there's
plenty there's
obviously a division in income and you
know what do you mean
it could be insulting to people i
understand that totally but what i don't
understand is how
that can be translated into you should
be bashful or ashamed of the fact that
you're successful i
i was uh i did a tv show for a long time
pilot didn't get picked up but they flew
me to um
we filmed it in belfast it was [ __ ]
amazing they're freaking north
trip to belfast so we film it there and
um the the network flew me first class
you know and i'm not
i'll be honest i i will not fly first
class unless someone else paid for it
but uh i was like this is i'm like wow
well you know uh they they beseech you
first
right in first class feel ashamed and as
as the first people started to come on
the the plane behind me
i was seriously like oh no i feel
horrible
and i thought to myself as i was flying
you know it's a long flight halfway
through i was like
wait a second would don draper
have been ashamed of sitting in first
class you know
it would where did that go where i i
assume
in 1965 a man in a business suit sitting
in first class
a guy comes down the aisle with his
child and he goes someday
you work hard you could be like him
whereas now it's like i know
let me hit my kid and go [ __ ] [ __ ] that
guy you know that's weird but but i
think it's a
society issue where like that should be
inspiring like when i see
kevin hart post something or the rock
postum or
uh you know anybody anybody tom sagur
when i see it it's like that's possible
so can like every podcaster should find
what rogan did where he made way more
money than reporting
that should be so inspirational for
everyone no one should always
sell it doesn't make sense you should
find that so inspirational
that you go holy [ __ ] that's possible in
podcasting right yes and people for
the past five years have been making
[ __ ] bank
podcasting me and brian are two [ __ ]
morons
and we make a good living doing this
without you you you guys two are our
best friends we're getting paid for this
it's crazy yeah because we decide to do
the show
that should be inspiring to everyone who
watches it but
me and brian aren't the smartest guys in
the room by far man i'm a [ __ ] [ __ ]
with ct
but people should find that stuff
inspiring right hate
it i i don't see i don't know where they
posted this was founded on that idea of
potential
like you may not be a millionaire today
but you will be tomorrow which has
stopped
revolution from happening in this
country yes as long as we protect that
american dream
as long as we protect the idea that if
you use your ideas
and if you are innovative and if you
take risks that's a huge part of you
take the risk
if you take the risk and you have the
[ __ ] effort and you're willing to
fail a lot
you can make it yeah and that's kind of
like you that's when you can get to be
53 and
do you know what i mean but the point is
okay right now we're at a low point
we're at a low point but we're going to
get back up we're going to fly back i
challenge anyone me and brian over there
about three times a week
go by spacex and and not find that
inspiring
right with the rocket ship and all this
stuff and it's
it's in the hood yeah and you know what
he did with just
his lot of land the buildings the
parking
the greenery the ficuses the spaceship
drive over there and not get inspired
yeah
by elon musk who you know there's a ton
of
astronomical engineers where the [ __ ] he
is there's a ton of those guys
but he took risk man it's about he went
you know what this is an issue i'm
trying to still taking risks
but people don't realize that when you
look at a business somebody started a
business and they got really successful
and people you hear a lot of the stuff
like the workers should share on the
profits and they should get just as much
uh the worker didn't take the risk guys
when you
create a company from an idea when you
come up with an idea and you build a
company around it
the amount of energy that goes
into that the amount of fires you have
to put out every single day and
financially
the financial the but mainly the risk i
actually
don't know anybody who's made a lot of
money who wasn't
poor at one point who didn't who didn't
lose it all at one point
so you know you're always riding that
balance you're always taking that risk
and it people that are willing to change
and
and go with the flow and adapt
adapt you've got to learn how to change
your [ __ ] approach but
but also say this it's also i would i
would assume with elon musk with anyone
who's made any sort of amount of money
they didn't do it because they thought
they i don't think elon musk
decided to make tesla or you know that
weird underground thing which we
we you know it's called but he wants to
put cars in it
that's fine subway but um i don't think
he's
he started any of that or we didn't
start the podcast or rogan to start the
podcast
and goes oh i'm going to make this
amount of money
this millions in the future no one no
one
started because of that right no one and
no one who any of the aforementioned
people especially who are doing
something really different
none of them i'm sure a lot of us in
this room included
had anybody going great idea
go for it never no i guarantee you there
was a bunch of comic friends of joe
rogans that were going
what are you wasting your time on like
go do tv and i was like no i really want
to do it
and i i i was there brian how many of
your friends made funny for doing the
podcast with me oh my god how many are
your friends
friends because you were doing podcasts
and the best part is what are you doing
buddy and i go dude i'm telling you so
many of my friends all my friends
all my friends what are you doing this
is all his acting buddies with his ghost
meeting
you're not making any money you guys are
talking about dumb [ __ ] they would take
me to the side i'm like why are you
doing this with brian this is the
wasteland one of my friends said you're
two 11 year olds in a tree house what
are you doing dude you should be acting
you should be on tv i guarantee you i
guarantee you you go down the list elon
musk
the game of thrones the walking dead any
genre of any type of business where
people are innovators
they had a litany of people going uh
yeah i mean we like the idea but um
could you tweak it this way and maybe do
a little less cussing not so much
violent and it's like no this is my
vision i'm to stick to it and after 10
15 20 years of getting hearing no no
they finally make it and all those
people are like
it's a great idea we've been pretty much
i've been supporting thinking that way
the whole time you know there's nothing
i i like the number one idea that comes
into my mind is like how many people
told um
matthew weiner i think his name is the
guy behind me the creator mad men yeah
matthew weiner i mean a legendary
collection of no's
nose nose we'll get the production
started and finally they pull the plug
all these different networks all these
different people all they they wanted to
change change change and finally he's
like you know i'm gonna stick them
and and this obscure amc which nobody
watched at the time
decides to take a chance on it and then
of course once it hits big
every [ __ ] every network's doing the
1960s
uh madison avenue [ __ ] new york city
skinny tie show yeah you know
of course yeah so we've we've known all
along this is the way to go it's [ __ ]
[ __ ]
but it makes you laugh i mean i i love
the stories you all
you guys always tell about the fox execs
where it's like this is what you need to
do to be successful
in a podcast because i got my black
belts in broadcast but also
by the way yeah and most of them work
for the zone which is also good
and not only that though but a lot of
people said no one's given they were
like you know you gotta
you gotta sign with this group because
they'll own fifty percent of it but
they'll get you and brendan was like
no no we're gonna own all of it yeah
which is better ourselves we'll just
figure it out
so so much of that is just being oily
that's the lone story you know the
stallone rocky story it's really an
amazing almost
unreal beautiful story that idea that he
had so much money thrown his way this
relatively unknown guy and they're like
we'll buy the story we'll make the movie
you'll get a production credit
we're gonna cast someone else though
he's like no no i'm rocky
yeah i'm rocky that's a mindset that's
followed him all the way
i think lebron james too it's i think uh
la or yesterday was his anniversary
signing with nike
before he signed with nike when he was a
senior in the
high school coming out reebok went up to
him that the guy who owns reebok goes
here's 10 million dollars but don't talk
to any other shoe company and
in a year we're gonna we're gonna sign
you a deal and he had
his mom and him nothing no i'm not going
to do that reebok and i'm not getting 10
million which should change his life
because i'm not going to do that
reports already signed a billion dollar
deal god damn with nike
god damn i would i could use i could
build that right
yeah it's a you listen first off you'll
be fine
spotify if you want to buy this guy dude
let me just say let's be subtle spotify
give us a number give me a call i'm
saying
you got a man right here who could maybe
help you out a little bit i don't know
many 53 year olds in good of shape as
you with any kind of [ __ ] thick [ __ ]
you got this
i like where your head is i'm thinking a
little porn browser
makes fun of my hair but i think it
looks good it's nice it frames my face
right now yeah yeah yeah yeah watch your
tongue
okay what's gonna happen what are you
gonna do
use some of that boxing you've been
doing
oh she was [ __ ] disrespected